i hate you evan i hope you lose evan i
hope your business goes bankrupt evan
evan you're a terrible person i spent
the first
40 some years of my life trying to be
somebody else i'll give you guys a
secret way to fast lane your way into
being more authentic
and there she is
hi
what's up it's mel robbins everybody i
thought you froze for a minute i was
like do i have connectivity problems
he's like frozen like this oh well i'm
just i'm i'm doing the double high five
you know i'm too excited where are you
that is beautiful i am in my screened in
porch at my house
here in boston there's this bed that
hangs from the ceiling there
that with our little lights from target
uh yeah that's where i am that is
amazing i'm jealous it looks beautiful
mel robbins everybody author of the new
york times best-selling book the high
five habit here it is
what what um
i mean it's had such an impact you see
so many people sharing all of the all of
the work inside growth as well people
sharing is there is there a favorite
story i know you had so many and you're
still kind of you're still in it but
is there something you can share just
just blew you away
well i can't read the reviews everybody
without crying
um so first of all for all of you that
have read the book or been following
along i don't know if you know this evan
but i am actually reading the book cover
to cover for free
on social media every day
um
you know because i know that there's
yeah youtube facebook instagram linkedin
we read a little bit every day and
answer questions
and i think the thing that's blowing me
away the most
is how universal
it is
to
be hard on yourself
to hate yourself
to
uh it goes even deeper than doubt evan
like the the critical voice in people's
minds is just relentless
and so a couple stories um
i've had a bunch of people write and say
that they're sober because of the high
five habit
and that they first heard about it
because people were sharing it in aaa
meetings and you know if you struggle
with addiction or a
lot of uh things that you regret
shame
can be something that keeps you from
ever feeling motivated or worthy of
changing and when you go to high five
yourself every morning without saying a
word it starts to demonstrate to your
brain that despite
what you've survived and despite what
you may have done that you still believe
you are worthy of love and support those
stories bring me to my needs uh people
that literally there was one line that
that uh somebody wrote that said
you know at the beginning of the book it
felt really good to know that you mel
believed in me and my ability to change
by the end of it nothing will stop me
again from believing in my own ability
to change my life and so just story
after story after story of people
having revelation after revelation about
how just profoundly
they have been hating on themselves and
rejecting themselves and talking
themselves out of
all the things that they want and
deserve in life and
how quickly
the switch flips
using science when you start to
high-five yourself in the mirror and use
the other tools in the book
i love it well you mentioned your
youtube channel quickly and in the
middle of all this mel also crossed one
million subscribers on youtube that's
right you're gonna get one of these in
the mail soon oh yeah does it come soon
uh it takes a little bit of time but
make sure you have to apply for anything
yeah expert at youtube they'll send you
they'll send you an email and just put
in what what you want to show up on
there and they'll send it to you but oh
wow um
i love it just just the impact that
you're having around the world with the
book with your content
one of the things that i love about you
and your brand is
you don't pretend like you've always got
it all figured out
you know like in the nicest way
you know it's like so many people come
on it's like well here's what you do to
be a success and you're like i'm still
trying to figure all this out myself
and
a lot of your
breakthroughs
seem to come as a result of you feeling
really low
and then you find something that
after all these experiments kind of
works and then you dive into the signs
and then you share it and
aren't afraid or maybe you are but still
the willingness to come out and share
what you're going through how did how
did that like people say be vulnerable
and be authentic you just kind of seem
to live it how did that
come to fruition for you
well like everything uh evan
in my life it came the hard way like i
kind of wish that i could just read this
stuff in a book and apply it like that
but i don't know if i'm just stubborn
or it i'm an experiential learner but as
you already said i kind of have to
either fall in a hole or dig one for
myself and then i got to build a ladder
in order to get out of that hole and so
that's that's how i come on to this
stuff and i think the other reason why
um i apologize if there's a i don't know
what that is some sort of airplane
flying around but i i don't know
why this is my learning style but it is
but i'll tell you what everybody
i spent the first
40 some years of my life trying to be
somebody else like i struggled with
people pleasing and insecurity just like
everybody else does and i don't care who
you are everybody feels
uh the desire to fit in the the need to
be liked and you know when you're really
a
professional people pleaser which i was
it typically also goes back to some form
of childhood trauma evan where
you think
that making sure everybody's okay
making sure mom's happy making sure
dad's not upset making sure you know
everybody's safe like whatever that sort
of hyper vigilance is
that that gets wired into your way of
being and that was me for a long time
like if i were
uh if you were talking to the old mel
robbins
12 15 years ago you i would have been
sitting here having a conversation with
you
assessing your facial
uh
you know expressions your reactions and
instead of just saying what comes to
mind naturally i'd be thinking in my
head what do i need to say to make evan
like me what do i need to say to make
evan think that i'm smart and it's
exhausting if you are somebody that
struggles with anxiety i guarantee you
there's a gigantic aspect of making sure
other people like you and people
pleasing which is all about your own
insecurity with yourself that's a part
of your day-to-day existence and so back
to your question
about how do you
how did you become so vulnerable how is
it that you can just throw all this
stuff out there and it's real it's not a
gimmick you're not doing it because you
think you're going to get more likes and
you're not doing it because everybody
says that people that are authentic or
you know have bigger brands or whatever
the hell it is you just do it because
that's who you are
i spent so long trying to be somebody
else
that i finally had a freaking
breakthrough at like the age of 45 that
it is so much easier
to just be yourself it's so much easier
and freeing i'll give you guys a secret
way to fast lane your way into being
more authentic
start saying
these three words more often
i don't
know
if you're in a meeting at work and
somebody asks you a question and you say
i don't know
something incredible happens your
credibility goes through the roof
because people in that nano second
realize holy cow if i'm talking to evan
and he's willing to say in front of 10
other people i don't know
i can try to figure it out for you but i
don't know the answer to that
people go i can trust him
because he's telling me the truth he's
admitting something i don't even want to
admit and so if you were to start to
look for opportunities every day to
either say i don't know
or
to say i don't know how many words are
in this sentence something like i'm
sorry evan i don't understand what
you're talking about
could you explain nfts to me again like
it it you that literally is
the magic formula for beginning
to be more authentic admit what you
don't know
there's this great clip on a major news
network it's cnn or cnbc one of those
and elon musk is on it and he's
basically saying that
robots are gonna kill us all and take
over the world
right it's like this big bold statement
and
then they ask them well how's it going
to happen
and he says i don't know
and then they asked him a couple more
questions the same thing is like i don't
know and i remember watching that to
your point like man i don't know that i
would have the courage to go on some
major platform make some bold claim and
then not know
the answer to any of the follow-up
questions i think our human nature would
be like oh let me try to stumble to find
an answer as opposed to just flat out
saying
i don't know
it's actually a power move everybody to
say i don't know or hey excuse me i i'm
not following what you guys are talking
about can you explain what xyz means or
i i don't know how to pronounce
pronounce this word that happens to me
all the time with my dyslexia just no
idea how to pronounce words and so
i think when you're willing to
say i don't know it's a way to put your
toe in the water and realize you're not
gonna die people actually don't laugh at
you they respect the fact that you're
saying something like that most people
if they know something that you don't
know love being smarter than you so
they're not going to penalize you
they're going to feel better around you
and the other thing that i've learned
through experience and you can read this
everybody and you can listen to evan and
i say this but until you experience it
yourself firsthand you will not believe
what i'm talking about is true
research shows
when you screw up
or stumble
or mispronounce something or forget what
you were supposed to say or you start to
look a little panic stricken if you're
speaking in class or you're giving a
presentation or you're doing a live
stream like evan and i are right now
when you screw up
the people watching
immediately flip into
feeling bad for you and then rooting for
you
so that i can't remember what the study
is you may know this evan about how like
if you've ever seen somebody trip up the
stairs
to get an award like at the oscars or
something when that happens we all go oh
no
or if you've ever been in the audience
when somebody's slides aren't working
and you start to feel this shared
experience of anxiety
people trust you more
they root for you because you're
stirring a shared experience with them
in your own humanity like something
interesting happened to me yesterday
evan if you'll allow me to explain this
as i mentioned i've been reading the
high five habit for free
on
all of my social media platforms
a little bit every day and answering
people's questions because i know a lot
of people are really hurting and they
can't even afford to buy the book and so
i'm you know basically saying to people
i'm going to show up here to make this
accessible because i know that the work
in this book the tools the research it's
transformational
yesterday
i had so many things go wrong i was 20
minutes late to getting our text set up
right unlike evan i'm not a genius at
this stuff
uh i'm not as organized as evan i'm not
as smart as evan i have not studied this
stuff the way that evan has and so i
sort of am like the bad news bears with
the live stream i thought i would do it
on the screened in porch we couldn't get
wi-fi i couldn't get one of the phones
to work i one of my i couldn't find the
right tripod i'm running late the team
is texting me so now i'm amped up i'm
now running into the the office
and i can't get it quite set up we start
going and we're 20 minutes late with an
advertised live stream i've got three
team members on remote trying to
organize getting it to linkedin getting
it to facebook so guys i'm performing on
camera i'm live
i'm late we've had tech breakdowns i'm
53 years old that the kind of adrenaline
is going through the roof you know this
evan you've experienced these things
before
the freaking
guy who i love who comes once every two
weeks
to mow the lawn shows up
and he is now got a leaf blower outside
the window as i'm going live
the computer crashes and we lose the
live stream
and just the people on instagram are now
watching
as i'm trying to talk to the team in
real time going do we just kill this
what are we doing i'm totally alone
there's a guy out here i'm turning the
thing and showing everybody i'm kind of
in this breakdown mode you see it happen
in real time and you know what i wanted
to do i wanted to go exit exit exit exit
get me out of here get me out of here
but i all of a sudden close the book and
i literally allowed
the real experience i just started
crying on instagram yesterday this is
yesterday everybody you're looking at
the woman who had the number two selling
book on all of amazon last week hit the
new york times uh the high five habit we
are
literally an instant bestseller because
of everybody's support because i know
this is the book the world needs right
now and because of the support of of so
many amazing friends like evan
but here i am crying on instagram
yesterday
just completely overwhelmed by my life
i look up the camera i've got my glasses
off i'm wiping my eyes i'm like does
anybody else feel overwhelmed by their
life right now
you know i know that it looks like i
have it all going on i know it looks
like my life is perfect it is not
like i like i'm just overwhelmed let me
let me show you a tool in the book let's
use it right now
do you know we posted that and typically
whatever it is that when we're posting
free chapters of the book
have been getting for views this thing
like 8xed
the other views and let me tell you why
because it's not about the views i you
and i think about views the same way
those are human beings and you and i
both want to make an impact
in people's lives and so the more people
that watch it the more lives you have a
chance to impact
and
the reason why everybody is going back
to evan's original question
nobody wants to be told what to fricking
do
we all want to feel something
and we don't want to be talked down to
and so i think in that moment
when you know here i am having just
launched the most successful thing i've
ever done in my entire career
and here i am crying
because i'm alone and i'm overwhelmed
and i'm screwing up left and right and
i've got no ability to control all these
things that are breaking down
everybody can relate to that feeling
everybody
and so my advice on being authentic
and being vulnerable is give yourself
permission to be you
all of
you it's so much easier everyone than
pretending
i love how you wrapped it up because i
don't remember even what my question was
i was so listening to your story
like oh yeah i did ask that question
i we're in this group together that our
mutual friend brendan burchard put
together of pretty much all the big
names in person development and
marketing and we had a great chance to
meet up in napa recently which was tons
of fun
one of the questions i
keep getting asked when people see all
of those pictures is what what's it like
hanging out with mount robbins yeah what
what's what's what's she really like
behind the scenes and what's it like
being with brendan burchard it's like
they all have their own issues too
nobody's perfect like i remember sitting
there talking about this and you're
worried that it wouldn't sell well you
know around the table
so so the question first off people
don't believe that but then the next
question becomes okay so you have all of
the same insecurities and fears and
doubts like wants the projects to work
and afraid that it's not going to work
out so that is super relatable but what
then makes the difference like if mel
robbins struggles with all the things
that average human struggles with
how do you then go on to achieve
extraordinary success when most people
don't
um so
there is probably a multi-layered answer
so i'll number it as i go along
um i think that
number one work ethic i'll outwork
anybody
um i know that the secret to success is
not getting it right
it's actually uh getting after it until
you get it done
and
um so work ethic work ethic work ethic
anything is possible if you are willing
to give up your timeline
and you're willing to put your head down
and put the work in
the second thing is um i
know
that failure
and screw-ups are a massive
uh
part of paving the road to success like
you know i'm not a lucky person that can
just study stuff and implement it and
then it all works out
i have this deeply personal process that
everybody shares by the way of studying
everybody who does it really well
and then implementing their best
practices and then tweaking it so that
it feels right and so failure screw-ups
detours
all of it uh is part of the road to
success
the third thing is and you know i write
about actually all of this stuff in the
high five habit
there is this mindset trick that i
created that is an entire chapter in the
high five habit that i created when i
was um
launching the five second rule book
which uh the hard cover
book was a huge failure believe it or
not
and um
when we launched the hardcover
uh it originally uh we had
the bottom line is that when i launched
the hardcover evan the hardcover was not
available for sale when my marketing
kicked off like there was a screw-up
with amazon i started marketing i told
everybody to go buy it and it read is
out of stock couldn't even pre-order it
it was like out of stock huge mix-up on
my part i was a self-published author
and as my attitude was going down the
drain i literally started saying this
thing to myself on repeat and everybody
you should just feel this um it's like
chapter 13 in the book
this moment is preparing me
this moment is preparing me
this moment is preparing me for
something amazing
that hasn't happened yet
and every single thing in my life
that has been a struggle or a hardship
or a heartbreak or
anything
even losing people i love to the disease
of hopelessness and addiction
those moments of going through
tremendous grief and heartache prepared
me to help other people to do it and so
when you can start to ground yourself in
this idea that i never really liked by
the way evan that whole phrase life is
happening for me
because there's a lot of that i didn't i
don't want it
i don't believe it's for me but there's
something about tweaking it like this is
preparing me it allows me to take
control of a situation i don't like i
didn't want i didn't plan for it's not
what i deserve but if it's preparing me
for something it flips my mindset into
this attitude that allows me
to endure it
and allows me to have perspective that
someday i will look back on it and
understand the wisdom that i gained from
it and so you know the failure of the
hardcover with the five-second rule
prepared me for something all right it
introduced me to my business model that
has a huge partnership with audible like
the five-second rule because of the
failure of the hardcover became the
most
sold and listened to audiobook of the
year of all of 2017 and opened up a
whole new business model
and you know which by the way is still
bearing out everybody because
as the book sells out around the world
it's the audiobook like we were the
number one selling audio book in the
world last week number two selling title
on amazon
because of the audiobook and so there's
a whole new business model i learned and
so you need to understand that every
failure that you have everybody
it is actually preparing you for
something else that's number three that
sort of attitude um the other thing
honestly
is i've been successful in spite of
myself evan
because it's only
since learning the high five habit
that i have been able to truly
reset my default thinking
and become
a person whose default is to cheer for
herself do i have insecurities yes do i
have self doubts yes but the one thing i
don't do anymore
is i do not beat the hell out of myself
anymore you see even all those years
everybody when uh my speaking career was
taking off i was literally my biggest
critic
it was never enough
it was well i kind of you know even
though the audience is giving me a
standing ovation and the clients just
hired me to do seven more events evan
i'm like well god i really screwed up
minute 43
i really blew it that time like i was
relentless with myself and there's a
difference everybody
between
having a level of excellence in what you
do
and high standards which i know evan has
a level of excellence in what he does
and he also marries his process with
excellence but that's very different
than relentless
self-criticism
you know what i mean
and and what happens with relentless
self-criticism self-hatred self-doubt
all of that beat down is that number one
you slow down your progress
number two you miss opportunities
number three
you uh lose inspiration and motivation
because everything is a grind
number four you have
no joy in what you're doing
because you are singularly focused on
finding stuff that's not going right
and number five
you literally will never be happy and
content
because you're not allowing yourself to
celebrate and empower yourself for all
the things you're doing right which only
creates more positive momentum and it
was the high five habits something i
created by mistake in april of 2020 that
completely changed my habits my attitude
the reason why this is the most
successful thing i've ever done is
because i'm different
uh using the high five habit i've asked
for help
i've i've gotten out of the insecurity
of needing to do it all myself i'm
enjoying the process of it even though
it's kind of a show behind the scenes
like this is
um
just the greatest gift in the world
because it changes how i experience my
life and that's the biggest thing
everybody that's the final takeaway in
terms of success and why most of you
don't have the success you deserve
because you're too hard on yourself
you are focused on what's not working
instead of celebrating what is
you're beating the hell out of yourself
every day which is demotivating
if you want to be more successful than
you could ever imagine
you must read the high five habit you
must start to put these practices in
place you must start to see the good you
must start to flip your attitude when
it's going down and you must must must
be able to use the tools in here to
become somebody that is supportive
encouraging of yourself
i love it and just to speak to your
willingness to ask for help as well as
just the work ethic
uh back in napa one of our field trips
was to go hot air ballooning and uh you
and i are both afraid of heights
it's like okay we're in that we're in
the same balloon together and it was
like a half hour 45 minute ride to get
there and and mel's sitting next to me
and uh when this little van and she
pulls out her notebook because i go
gavin tell me everything that's wrong
with my youtube channel i i don't have
the answers but i'm going to take notes
i'm going to make sure that this happens
so be honest and tell me you like rip it
apart it's like okay
and we did a jam session all the way up
and so
i love how you you know are constantly
trying to learn and maximize the time
and even if it's something that is you
know you're not going to be the one
updating thumbnails and tweaking titles
and even though you don't fully
understand it we work today there we go
i love it
yup but no i i think that's it too evan
and you're like this thank you for the
comment you're the exact same that's why
you see it in me
we are both learners
like i think this is the greatest thing
in the world everybody
to like of course i want to update
thumbnails and and and obsess over
titles because that's the art of this
and unless you're willing to be a
student
of what you're doing
you'll never be able
to teach the things that you've learned
and so you know i think that you know
evan
is such a student
of his craft it's why he has so much
success
and he's having a lot of fun because he
brings a student mindset to what he's
doing
i love it well listen everybody you got
to pick up the high five habit uh one of
the things that i loved in here was
it seems very basic but
one of the chapters you i think it's
chapter three you lead people into
how do you do a high five
i got a train going by so i'm gonna go
in the house while they blow their horn
go ahead it's great it's great ambiance
it feels like uh
very it's something very basic but i
remember okay i'm gonna do the high five
habit i'm gonna do this with mel she's
she's challenged us all to do this so
you know i get to my mirror and like oh
what do i do just do that's it and i
think that
the moment of of calm
and just a moment of of clarity and the
moment of like just take a pause before
you do it
is is everything like the five seconds
before you do the high five at least for
me
feels like everything because it just
allows you to be more present with what
you're doing yeah and i love how basic
you make it i mean i think you you
something sometimes use the word like
it's so stupid
which i'm not a huge purpose by the way
because i'm speaking into the objection
that people have yeah and so you know a
couple things that's been really
interesting about the process everybody
of um
writing this book i learned so for those
of you that are interested in writing a
book and you know for you evan i think
you'll appreciate this sort of ins
insight and that is that i'm kind of
bummed
that i
published the book and then did all
these podcasts because it's in the
speaking through it everyone and
answering questions that have gone even
a layer deeper
into understanding all of this and so
the book doesn't even contain half of
the really
deep amazing things like it doesn't
pound it into you like for example i
didn't know until after
i
published the book and i was on the
podcast tour talking to our friend dr
daniel amen that the reason why the high
five habit feels so good is because your
brain gives you a tripod dopamine when
you do it it's not even in the book i
mean it's it's it's because your brain
has neural association that's triggered
by this physical movement and so there's
some really exciting things that i've
since learned and here's the simplicity
of it i don't even want anybody when you
stand in front of the mirror first of
all put your toothbrush down we're going
to do it right after you brush your
teeth get the gunk out of your mouth and
let's get the gunk out of your mind body
and spirit that's number one secondly we
know when you pair this new high five
habit with brushing your teeth you're
more likely to remember to do it based
on science we're going to stack the
habits
three you're right just take a second
the power of it is twofold it's it's in
breaking
the habit of self-rejection
that everybody has that is part of their
morning routine
and i don't even expand on this enough
in the book in my opinion you know we
talk about meditation gratitude all
these things that should be part of your
morning routine
nobody
has really revealed that every human
being has an ugly habit
every morning in the mirror of
self-rejection
50 of men and women can't even
look
at themselves in the mirror that's how
bad it is
that's how common it is to reject
yourself if you can't even look at
yourself in the mirror and how many of
you uh feel that way
put it in the comments if you actually
cannot if you're one of the 50 of men
and women who just don't even look at
yourself in the mirror you're disgusted
with
your weight you're disgusted with what
you've done in your life you're
disgusted that you haven't you're not
where you thought you should be you have
such a negative dialogue you hide in the
back of photos with friends like you
know if i'm talking to you
that by the way the inability to look at
yourself in the mirror evan
is a habit of rejecting self
boom that's part of everybody's morning
routine if you can look in the mirror
what the rest of us do is we focus on
the things we want to fix
that's another habit of self-rejection
and so i believe that the reason why
people are chasing external validation
and why everybody struggles with so much
anxiety and people pleasing
is because we are insecure with
ourselves because we're constantly
rejecting ourself
and so i want you to understand i'm out
to do something more than teaching you
to high five i'm out to break this
freaking habit i'm out to break the
habit of self-rejection and replace it
in your morning routine with a habit of
self-acceptance
a habit of self-worth
a habit of self-respect and ultimately
and eventually a habit of
self-love
and so as you stare at yourself which
for many people is super uncomfortable
it's gonna feel weird because
it's the opposite of what you currently
do so if it feels weird when you look at
yourself evan that's good news because
it means it's working you're plowing a
new neural pathway in your brain good
job
when you go to raise your hand i don't
even want you to say anything no mantras
nothing because the gesture alone is so
powerful
it's unlocking programming and neural
association in your brain and your
nervous system and in your physiology to
work for you so you literally go up and
you go to raise your hand and your brain
doesn't know the difference between me
high-fiving myself or me high-fiving
evan it's a fact
because it's such a physical motion that
you've done forever your brain's like oh
here we go high five give her some
dopamine and the nervous system's like
oh a high five let's do some celebratory
energy little jolt the reason why people
laugh or cry but you feel a little bit
better as you leave the bathroom that
literally it's because of the dopamine
in the nervous system
and you can stand in front of the mirror
and be like i hate myself
uh look at my freaking stomach look at
how ugly and old and look at these lines
but the second you raise your hand the
physical movement
that beat down silences because you've
never high-fived somebody else evan and
thought i hate you evan i hope you lose
evan i hope your business goes bankrupt
evan evan you're a terrible person
you're a bet like you know what i mean
you've never done that
it's
neurologically impossible for your brain
to think anything but oh i believe in
you i support you i see you i love you
all of it
and it's because of the programming
that's already in your mind so the way
you do it is simple stand with yourself
break the habit of self-rejection look
past your face and into your eyes that's
not your reflection that's another human
being
be with that human being because that
human being needs you and they're trying
hard and they're tired of you beating
them up
and then you're just going to raise your
hand
and high-five that person and you don't
have to think anything just let the
physical motion do it for five lousy
days in fact growth that
growthdaydeal.com
five lousy days there's a free high five
challenge that i've created with brendan
evans partnered with us everybody listen
to me right now
121 000 people have gone through
45 000 comments it's not on facebook it
is on a tech platform called growth day
so that you don't have to do ads and
cross posting and all this stuff and you
don't have to buy anything you get this
thing for five days use it love it
interact with people every day we send
you an email you get a video training
for me you get a journal prompt that is
grounded in science once you're done
with the journal prompt we're asking you
to share what you learned in the
comments with 121
000 people around the world who are
trying to break through self-doubt and
learn how to take control of their lives
just like you
just like you are and by the end of the
five days you will feel like a different
human being period
so we've linked that up here on
instagram growthdaydeal.com youtube will
put it in the description below
can you quickly talk to us about
jealousy because your version of it is
very different
than most people and i love it and i'd
love for you to expand on it
yeah um
you know
we miss on we none of us understand what
jealousy actually is and that's why it
consumes you and paralyzes you
jealousy is a good thing
because jealousy
is a
directional
signal
jealousy
is a signal that there is something that
you
desire
that you're not
working on getting in your own life and
i'm going to unpack this for a second
because it's so powerful when you
understand jealousy when you don't
understand jealousy
and you think jealousy makes you a bad
person or jealousy or and look i get a
lot of people like if that's not
jealousy that's envy i don't care what
you call it you know that feeling where
you kind of like somebody has something
and then you either don't like them or
you want it and then you feel bad and
guilty about wanting it or then you feel
defeated because you have it all of that
is what i'm talking about whether you
call it envy or jealousy or whatever it
may be desire that that paralyzes you
um
i used to be consumed by jealousy evan
because i was insecure
and i
did not like myself
and i did not treat myself with respect
so i did not believe i was worthy of
having good things
and so i would look around and i would
see what everybody else has whether they
had a nicer house or they could go on
big vacations or they had a bigger bank
account or they uh had a loving marriage
or whatever it may be
and i would feel this wave of envy and
jealousy consume me
and the interesting thing about jealousy
is that a couple things number one if
you are prone to feeling jealous
jealousy is not motivating
jealousy makes you feel worse about
yourself and it paralyzes you
but here's the thing i want you to start
to flip your mind i call this flipping
it from a jealousy mindset into a high
five attitude
if jealousy is just trying to signal you
towards something that you desire
then all that jealousy is is it is
blocked desire
that's it it's just blocked inspiration
blocked desire it is blocked by your
insecurity it is blocked by your
self-loathing it is blocked by your fear
it is blocked by your mindset
and so this is why the high five is so
important because that high five every
morning clears away the blocks and
allows you to connect back with what you
really want and who you really are and
so fact number one about jealousy
everybody it's not a bad thing
it is a good thing because it is a
marker on the map of your life trying to
get you to pay attention and turn your
life in a certain direction number two
jealousy is just blocked desire and
inspiration
number three
jealousy is deeply personal
because you can only be jealous of
something you actually won
so
i'm not the least bit jealous right now
i'm using this example i'm not the least
bit jealous
our friend dean for example has this
unbelievable mansion
uh in this unbelievable town
and i'm not jealous at all because i
don't want to live where he lives
right
so
jealousy is personal for you
and so i can tell you for example i'm
super jealous of all of our friends that
have podcasts because i've been thinking
about launching a podcast for seven
years and when i didn't understand
jealousy i would make my jealousy uh
make me feel worse i would say oh louis
started eight years ago i should have
started eight years ago now i would just
be a copycat there's all two million
podcasts i'm too late i'm too this and
so instead of leaning toward what i
wanted and doing the work i would use
that jealousy to keep me feeling
paralyzed and angry okay that's number
one number two i'm jealous of evan
i'm jealous of evan because he is the
youtube master he understands the
platform better than anybody and so i
would look at evan's channel and i would
cross my arms i'd be like i'm so jealous
of evan and then i go he must have a
team of 50 000 people and like if now
that i understand what jealousy is
jealousy is not a sickness of the heart
as somebody's saying jealousy is just
literally something blocking your heart
that's it it's not a sickness it is
literally something's blocked that's it
it's not good or bad it just is blocked
by insecurity that's all that it is and
your heart is trying to tell you what
you want i want to understand youtube i
want to put out more content there's not
enough women on youtube in the personal
development space putting out tons and
tons of how-to content and coaching
content and we're about to roll into
that space so get ready in a major way
thanks to evan's help but when you're
blocked by insecurity you sit in your
corner and you talk yourself out of
reaching out to evan
when you realize this is something you
desire you become more empowered and
curious and a student of it and you feel
equipped and evan doesn't become
somebody that i look at with envy evan
becomes a light
on the path
ahead of me
a co-creator in this marvelous life of
mine and yours and so
that is the opportunity of jealousy
honor it back in the day evan when you
know jealousy would consume me when
chris and i were struggling financially
we had leans on the house
uh he was out of the restaurant business
i was just starting in the speaking
business we were barely making the ends
meet i would go into somebody's house
where they were renovating their kitchen
and i would literally want to
self-destruct
literally and then we would get back in
the car
and my husband you know would be in the
seat next to me and instead of since i
didn't understand jealousy and i it
feels so awful to feel it when you don't
understand it i would literally turn on
me like why can't you be more successful
why did you have to like i would
literally aim at all it's so toxic my
behavior because i just didn't know
and what i realize now
is that i was jealous of like people
going on vacations and people uh
renovating their houses not because i
necessarily wanted those things
but because i had so much ambition
to go build something of my own
and i was not
allowing myself to lean into that
because of my insecurity and fear
and that jealousy was like a bell going
wake up wake up this is you know it's
not the kitchen mel you want to build
something
mel it's not the fancy vacations you
want freedom to be able to
take your family places you want to you
have ambition mel
lean into that don't make yourself wrong
like unpack the things that you're
jealous of everybody because it is an
invaluable
invaluable
directional signal you're meant for
something
and you need to unpack what it is about
that jealousy what is it about what
evan's doing that makes me jealous well
it's that i feel like he understands it
and he's got this mission and he's got a
cadence about it and i'm
i could be further from the truth is
slapping it all together and trying to
figure it out and and i realized that
there is an excellence
and a methodology with which evan
operates that i'm jealous of because i
have not slowed down long enough to flip
into becoming a student
and experimenting and turning toward it
but now i am
you you cornered me in the vein you know
on our hot on balloon ride and we're
gonna make it happen we're gonna we're
gonna get mel to 10 million the first
person in thought leadership that hit 10
million let's go
um yeah mel i mean your story your time
is always much appreciated now before we
go i know you partnered with growth day
brendan
all of this stuff having a huge impact
the link is growthdaydeal.com
for people who go there what are they
going to get
so you go straight to a landing page you
need a first name and an email that's it
and then log into growth day you can
take it anywhere you have internet
access you can log into a url you can
log in and download the app if that's
what you want to do if you're getting a
sign that you've got to pay for the app
you do not need to go back to
growthdaydeal.com we have arranged evan
and i to get you access to growth day
for free for the five days of this
challenge and so on day one it's the
same you get you literally will step
into the challenge with 121 000 people
there's already 45 000 comments selfies
of people from around the world doing it
with their kids their colleagues they're
it's incredible
and um
day one you're going to get a video and
the videos are anywhere from 15 minutes
to a half an hour of me teaching you the
concepts in the book
then right after the video you do a
journal prompt and then right after you
do the journal prompt you're taken to
the comments it's all just like we
breadcrumb you it's so easy and in the
comments you share what you're learning
and that inspires other people and then
other people high-five you back and
comment back and you realize oh my gosh
i
literally have been feeling so alone
i literally
needed this this is exactly what you
need if you want a boost of energy if
you want to start believing in yourself
again if you want more confidence if you
feel like these last 18 months have just
punched you in the face and it is time
to feel good again it is time to take
control of your life this five day free
challenge
is exactly what you need exactly what
you need
there it is growth
daydeal.com go check it out mount
robbins we love you
you're the best thank you for having me
bye everybody we'll talk to you soon
much love absolutely if you want to see
the one-on-one i did with marie forleo
recently check it out right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there most of
us exist in this space of endless
comparison the compare and despair right
so we have either these idealized
versions of ourselves that we're
constantly comparing ourselves to